foreign
Computing the competition for leadership
is a quite tough three-way race Amazon
web services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform clearly are the top Cloud
companies who have a commanding lead in
the infrastructure as a service and
platform as service markets hey everyone
I'm Lance and I want to welcome you all
to this new video from Simply learn on
AWS versus Azure versus gcp in this
video we will compare and contrast AWS
Azure and gcp based on a few related
Concepts around these cloud computing
platforms it will help us understand the
functioning of these top Cloud platforms
and will also let us figure out the
individuality of each one of them but
before starting with the comparison
let's have a quick introduction of AWS
versus Azure versus gcp so let's get
started
Amazon web services or AWS is a cloud
computing platform that manages and
maintains hardware and infrastructure
reducing the expense and complexity of
purchasing and running resources on site
for businesses and individuals
these resources are available for free
or for a fee per usage
Microsoft Azure is a cloud computing
service that offers a collection of
Cloud Computing Services for building
testing deploying and managing
applications in the cloud including
remotely hosted and managed versions of
Microsoft Technology
Google Cloud platform offers a variety
of Cloud Computing Services for building
deploying scaling monitoring and
operating a cloud
the services are identical to those that
power Google products such as Google
search Gmail YouTube and Google Drive
now let's move on to the comparison
between AWS Azure and gcp
we will be comparing them based on a few
major parameters like origin
service integration
availability Zone
Cloud tools like compute
storage
networking
market share
pricing
and at last who uses them
now let's move ahead and start with the
first comparison origin
in the year 2006 Amazon web services or
AWS was introduced to the market
and in the year 2010 Azure launched its
services whereas on the other hand gcp
was established in the year 2008.
from the start AWS has been supportive
of the open source concept but the open
source Community has a tense
relationship with azure
on the other hand gcp similar to AWS
provides Google cloud with managed open
source services that are tightly linked
AWS offers services on a large and
complex scale that could be manipulated
but Azure support is comparatively low
quality whereas gcp's monthly support
price is almost a hundred and fifty
dollars for the silver class which is
the most basic of services and is quite
expensive
now let's move on to the service
integration of these Cloud platforms
service integration is a set of tools
and technology that connects different
applications systems repositories and
data and process interchange in real
time
AWS makes it simple for users to combine
services such as Amazon ec2 Amazon S3
Beanstalk and others and on the other
hand Azure allows customers to
effortlessly combine Azure VMS as your
app service SQL databases and other
services whereas users can utilize gcp
to combine services such as compute
engine cloud storage and Cloud SQL now
that we know briefly about all these
Cloud platforms let's have a look at the
availability zones of these platforms
because AWS was the first in the cloud
domain they have had more time to build
and extend their network but Azure and
gcp both have various locations around
the world
but the distinction is in the amount of
availability zones they have AWS now
offers 66 availability zones with an
additional 12 on the pipeline close to
it Azure is available in 140 countries
and is available in 54 regions
throughout the world but Google Cloud
platform is now available in 20 Global
areas with three more on the way
now let's move on to the next important
factor which is tools
now let's move ahead and have a look at
the first feature which is compute
elastic compute cloud or ec2 is aws's
compute service which offers a wide
range of features including a large
number of instances support for both
windows and Linux high performance
Computing and more Azure on the other
hand as virtual machines is Microsoft
azure's core cloud-based compute
solution
it includes Linux Windows server and
other operating systems as well as
better security and Microsoft program
integration
in comparison to its competitors
Google's Computing Services catalog is
somewhat smaller compute engine that
companies principal service offers
custom and pre-defined machine types per
second invoicing Linux and Windows
support and carbon neutral
infrastructure that uses half the energy
of traditional data centers
within the compute category Amazon's
different container services are gaining
prominence it has Docker kubernetes and
it's also fargate service which
automates server and cluster management
when using containers as well as other
alternatives
Azure unlike AWS uses virtual machine
scale sets of two container services
Azure container services is based on
kubernetes and container service uses
Docker Hub and Azure container registry
for management
for Enterprises interested in deploying
containers Google offers the kubernetes
engine and it's also worth noting that
Google was significantly involved in the
kubernetes project providing an
extensive knowledge in this field
now let's move on to the next parameter
of comparison which is storage
simple storage service for object
storage elastic block storage for
persistent block storage and elastic
file system for file storage are among
aws's storage offerings
yeah block storage for rest based object
storage of unstructured data Q storage
for a large volume workload file storage
and disk storage are among Microsoft
Azure core storage services
gcp offers an increasing number of
storage options its unified object
storage service cloud storage also has a
persistent disk option relational
database service or RDS
dynamodb no SQL database elastic and
memory data store redshift data
warehouse Neptune graph database and
database migration service are all SQL
compatible databases offered by Amazon
the database choices in Azure are
specifically wide SQL database mySQL
database and postgre SQL database are
the three SQL based choices
now when it comes to databases gcp
offers the sql-based cloud SQL and Cloud
spanner a relational database built for
Mission critical workloads now the next
parameter is networking
AWS uses Amazon virtual private cloud or
VPC
on the other hand Azure uses Azure
virtual Network or v-net
and gcp uses Cloud virtual Network now
let's move on to another factor which is
market share and pricing
all these cloud services are based on
comparative pricing strategies which
means you need to pay on the basis of
its usage
according to Canalis the worldwide Cloud
Market Rose 35 percent to 41.8 billion
in the first quarter of 2021. AWS
accounts for 32 percent of the market
with Azure accounting for 19 and Google
accounting for seven percent
on one hand Amazon charges on a yearly
basis and on the other hand Microsoft
Azure and Google services charge on a
minute basis and also all of them
provide you a standard price for you to
access these services
AWS charges roughly 69 dollars per month
for a very basic instance with two
virtual CPUs and eight gigabytes of RAM
and AWS largest instance with 3.84 TB of
RAM and 128 vcpus will set you back
roughly
3.97 per hour but in Azure the same type
of instance one with two vcpus and eight
gigabytes of RAM cost roughly 70 U.S per
month and azure's largest instance has
3.89 TB of RAM and 128 virtual CPUs and
it cost about
6.79 per hour
compared to AWS gcp will supply you with
the most basic instance which includes
two virtual CPUs and eight gigabytes of
RAM for 25 percent less and as a result
it will set you back roughly 52 dollars
every month and the largest instance
that includes is 3.75 TB of RAM and 160
vcpus and it will cost you about 5.32
cents per hour
Amazon other than this also provides
spot instances reserved instances and
dedicated hosts where you can look for
multiple offers and discounts
but for Azure it provides special prices
to developers based on situations or
even Azure hybrid benefit which benefits
your organization up to 40 percent if it
uses Microsoft software in their data
centers
whereas Google offers quite assorted
pricing to its customer compared to the
other two
it gives you sustained use discounts
which activate if you use the same
instance for a month
the pronable instance which is very
similar to Amazon's spot instances but
one thing is common in all three cloud
services which is that they all offer
long-term discounts
now let's have a look at the last
comparison which is the companies that
are using them
because AWS is the oldest player in the
cloud business it has the largest user
base and Community Support as a result
AWS has the largest number of
high-profile and well-known clients
including Netflix Airbnb Unilever BMW
Samsung missinga and others
with time Azure is getting a large
number of high-profile customers as
you're currently boasts around 80
percent of Fortune 500 firms as
customers Johnson Controls polycom
Fujifilm HP Honeywell apple and others
are among its key clients
Google Cloud on the other hand uses the
same infrastructure as Google search and
YouTube and as a result many high-end
Enterprises trust Google Cloud HSBC
PayPal 20th Century Fox Bloomberg
Domino's and other are among Google
Cloud's many clients so this was all
about AWS versus Azure versus gcp and
we've almost reached the end of this
video now if I missed anything important
please let me know in the comments
section and I hope you enjoy this video
on AWS versus Azure versus gcp and have
learned something new from it if you
like this video then please hit that
like button and thanks for watching this
video and stay tuned for more updates
and videos from Simply
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here